[Music]
here in this list are 10 of the scariest
alien monsters that have invaded Earth
in movies these entries will not be
giant monsters nor the ones which are
basically just us with pointy ears but
they will be a good watch for this
Halloween so let's get to
it so this is a top 10 and starting with
number 10 we have the white spikes seen
in the movie called The Tomorrow War
humans are drafted into a future war
against these aliens known as the white
spikes these aliens devastate Earth in
248 ad prompting time travel to recruit
soldiers these white Spike alien
monsters were engineered as biological
weapons by another alien Ray reptilian
ones they have a fast breeding rate
insatiable hunger and a rageful
aggression spreading like a plague
across the Earth killing everything
everything inide humans animals whatever
their bodies are white and mostly
bulletproof and they have a terrifying
face with a mouth full of spiky teeth
and they have four legs with two smaller
arms on the chest they have two eyes
located on each side of their heads
giving them a wide feel of vision
unusual for a carnivore and they are
capable of night vision seen acting on
feral instincts they attack and kill
anything that moves and pushes the
entire planet to the bring of absolute
Extinction at number n we have the green
aliens so these are from the movie Signs
which is a must-watch for any sci-fi and
horror fan the aliens in the movie
resemble tall strangely humanite
creatures with green skin reminiscent of
classic gray aliens but they possess an
eerie and Supernatural aspect around
them as well they exhibit remarkable
agility capable of jumping to rooftops
effortlessly and are usually seen at
night in Split Second glimpses and also
they stalk their victims with great
suspense their skin can change colors
allow them to camouflage and go
unnoticed during their Invasion which
was portrayed as an ominous event that
happens worldwide as if it was the
apocalypse these aliens have wrist
spikes and can release a poisonous gas
interestingly though water proves to be
their weakness causing intense pain and
indicating an unknown biochemical
solvent for their
species number eight the thing this is a
classic alien and eldrich monster the
thing featured in a 1982 film of the
same name and also recent sequels is a
hostile extraterrestrial organism with
shape-shifting abilities its Origins
original characteristics and motivations
remain unknown as it assimilates other
life forms to survive and propagate the
thing lacks a standard anatomy and may
function as a colonial organism with
assimilation instructions at the genetic
level resilient to damage it can
reconstitute itself but it is vulnerable
to Fire and molecular acids which
destroys it at the cellular level the
creature though can tolerate extreme to
entering cryogenic stasis until
encountered by unsuspecting victims
during shape shifting it exhibits
bizarre forms incorporating tentacles
insect like limbs eyes teeth Claws and
faces to mimic desired shapes it brings
forward both go Terror and Cosmic horror
elements number seven martians these are
aliens that were seen in the movie
called The War of the Worlds the Tom
Cruz movie not the Flop Series where the
S line diverges greatly from The Source
material thus in turn bombing the views
also directed by Steven Spiel book so
you know this would be good right from
the bat despite being seen only in a few
scenes the aliens here feature two Small
Arms by their chest along with two
elongated slender arms boasting three
fingers on each hand they have a single
leg in addition to their arms and a
triangular shaped head remniscent of the
tripods their black eyes and two sets of
sharp teeth suggest High Intelligence
what gives them the horror aspect is the
fact that they harvest humans churning
the biomass which acts as fertilizer to
their red wheat plant life it is also
their ability to crash the entire world
into a pre electricity age that gives
them a worthy
shiver number six the kites seen in
Critters and its sequels they are the
new line Cinema response to Gremlins the
story centers around malevolent
carnivorous extraterrestrial called the
Crites these creatures can roll into
balls like hedgehogs and combined to
form a giant rolling sphere individually
kites resemble small f spiky animals
with large mouths filled with sharp
teeth throughout the franchise they
voraciously consume anything in their
path including humans the spikes on
their backs can be launched as
projectiles rendering victims
unconscious Crites come in black brown
and navy blue colors while the first
film depicts them as growing to a
largest size this ability was abandoned
in later installments The Narrative of
the first two films that revolves around
alien bounty hunters pursuing cres in a
small American town the third is set in
a City and the fourth on a space
station number five The Blob seen in the
movie of the same name the blob is an
amorphous gelatinous alien entity that
was brought to planet Earth trapped
inside a meteorite its Origins remain
shrouded in mystery with nothing known
about its natural habits of prevalence
in the vast Cosmos this shape-shifting
creature defies definition possessing
neither a fixed form or size it mes at
will swiftly engulfing and consuming all
living beings in its SP its method of
digestion is chemical assimilation
growing larger and more formidable with
each kill initially transparent white it
transforms into a Sinister dark reddish
purple Hue a stained with the blood of
its victims terrifyingly The Blob eludes
any known method of extermination it
only recalls from cold temperature
causing it to become dant until it
becomes warm again number four Calvin
Calvin of the 2017 science fiction
horror film called live emerges as a
nightmarish m multicellular alien entity
originating from Mars it stands as a
presumed Annihilator of all life on the
red planet evolving into an apex
predator of unparalleled ferocity this
deadly organism thrives on oxygen yet
possesses the unnerving ability to
suspend its need for it enduring even
the vacuum in space Calvin under goes a
grotesque transformation evolving into a
monstrous entity that breaks free
unleashing chaos throughout the confined
corridors of the space station it was in
Calvin's appearance is other the worldly
and horrifying resembling a white
translucent starfish its most remarkable
and horrifying aspect is its rapid
Evolution and the need to feed and in
the end of the movie it might be teased
that the alien has arrived on the planet
and nothing can stop it but this is left
for the mind to
wonder number three the death's angels
seen in the movie a quiet place and its
sequel the death Angels arrive on Earth
via a meteorite leading to a massacre of
almost all life these monsters possess
chitten armor covering their entire
bodies making them bulletproof they use
their limbs solely for movement and to
kill with blonde Force hits blind but
highly attuned to sound death angels
have extendable plates on their faces to
pin point to the direction of sound like
echolocation their heads unfold to a
massive eardrum like organ heightening
their hearing in this horrifying
scenario they relentlessly hunt their
prey by sound making survivors fear each
sound and keeping utterly quiet
throughout the entire length of the
movie up to a point where even the
viewer also Whispers to friends after
that
movie number two the graes so this is a
new alien that was seen in this year's
no one will save you movie which had a
very confusing ending nevertheless the
entire theme of the movie held up its
promise of an alien horror flick set in
a strange town with temporal anomalies
and a mix of timelines the aliens add to
the hisory and Horror by appearing
during the nighttime and attacking an
individual there were three types of
these aliens a humaniz one which had
telekinetic Powers a smaller monkey
likee alien a gray alien but with
unparal ferocity and also a tall alien
with Slender legs and also a horrifying
appearance they also had a strange
parasite that sends shivers down the
spine give this movie a chance I tell
you in any way it will be better and
Fresher a fresher watch at least than
the recent Insidious or Conjuring
flicks and number one xenom moves of
course if we talk about scary aliens no
list is valid without the inclusion of
the actual OG horror alien later renamed
as the zenom moves seen in many movies
they invade Earth in the AP and AP
requium timeline and also the last
really Scots alien movie they are
vaguely humanoid with black skin and a
strangely metallic organic makeup they
St in the dark and kill with feral
wildness but at the same time possessing
a dark sentience Xenomorphs are The
Benchmark of alien horror and to not see
their movies is an entertainment sin for
it isn't just their adult specimens that
kill but even their entire life cycle
from the babies which are the eggs and
the face huggers and the chest bursts
that all kill so do watch the
aliens so those are the 10 scarious
alien monsters that have invaded Earth
in movies of course so if you like this
video then watch this one as well and if
you're more interested in other movie
Monsters content and creatures then
check out our Channel as well we might
just have things that you haven't seen
before or even thought about like
subscribe and we'll see you on the next
video till the next one take care fam